Gianni Versace was a brilliant businessman
who took his humble beginnings and built a
multi-billion dollar fashion empire.
He became a celebrity designer, and his company’s
famous Medusa logo is recognized around the
world.
But in 1997, his life was cut short when he
became the victim of a serial killer.
On today’s Biographics, we will tell the
inspiring story of Gianni Versace’s rags-to-riches
success story, as well as the shocking twist
that ended his life.
Life in Italy
Gianni Versace was born on December 2nd, 1946
in Reggio Calabria, Italy.
He had two older siblings; a brother named
Santo, and a sister named Francesca.
His parents ran a dressmaking business.
His father handled the sales, while his mother
managed their staff with sewing and assembly.
Tragically, his older sister Francesca died
at 12 years old from a tetanus infection that
had gone untreated.
When he was 10, his parents decided to have
another child, and his younger sister Donatella
was born.
Gianni treasured baby Donatella, and they
would grow up to become best friends.
All his life, Gianni Versace loved classical
music and opera, and he had a dream of becoming
a professional composer.
However, his parents needed help around the
dress shop, and he was forced to give up his
dream in order to enter the family business.
He learned how to select fabrics, sew, sketch,
and create dress patterns for new designs.
During his apprenticeship, Gianni paid close
attention to his parents.
They knew how to make their clients feel comfortable,
and when these women looked in the mirror
with their new dresses, his mother made sure
they felt like they were the most important
person in the room.
Since his parents were both so busy running
the family business, he spent a lot of time
babysitting little Donatella.
One day, Gianni took his sister to visit the
Roman Colosseum.
This is when he came face-to-face with the
statue of Medusa.
He was so entranced by this terrifying woman
with hair made of snakes.
In school, Versace was studying Greek and
Latin, and he began to learn more about the
original mythology of Medusa.
He didn’t know it at the time, but this
legend would eventually make a huge impact
on his future company.
Most people know the legend of the monster
whose eyes could turn men to stone.
Maybe you already know the story of Perseus,
who chopped off her head and used it as his
own personal shield.
But Medusa’s backstory is actually far more
complex.
Medusa was born a mortal woman, and she worked
in the temple of Athena.
These priestesses swore a vow of chastity,
and covered up in modest attire.
Even so, Medusa was so beautiful, that news
spread about her, and Athena became jealous
and resentful.
The god of the sea, Poseidon, lusted after
Medusa.
One day, she was walking along the shore,
and Poseidon emerged from the sea to kidnap
and forced himself upon her.
Instead of acknowledging that she was a victim,
Athena claimed that Medusa was asking for
it, and violated her oath of purity.
Athena transformed her into a monster with
snakes for hair.
Now, every time she looked at a man, he would
turn to stone, which guaranteed that she would
be alone forever.
The true moral of the story was that even
the gods were not above petty jealousy.
Gianni Versace was completely inspired by
the story of Medusa.
In most artistic renderings, she is always
either naked or just-barely clothed.
With her curse came great power, because there
was no way she would ever be attacked by a
man again.
For Medusa, there was no need to dress modestly.
Versace would sketch pictures of the kinds
of dresses he imagined Medusa would wear.
These clothes had bright colors, and showed
off a woman’s curves.
He carried on this style for the rest of his
career.
Years later, the face of Medusa became the
logo of the Versace brand.
Growing the Versace Brand
At age 26, Gianni Versace decided that he
wanted to take his skills to the next level
by moving to Milan and immersing himself in
the world of luxury fashion.
He got a job for a clothing manufacturer named
Genny’s.
While he was under their employment, he was
able to design two of his own lines of ready-to-wear
clothing.
After building this portfolio, he began working
for other well-established Italian fashion
houses.
Versace spent 6 years living and working in
Milan gaining valuable experience and networking
with people in the fashion industry.
He eventually made a collection of his original
pieces, and they were on display at the Palazzo
della Permanente Art Museum.
This exhibit was a smashing success, and it
got him enough inquiries from new clients
to where he could start selling pieces direct
to customers.
In 1978, when Gianni Versace was 32 years
old, he was finally ready to open his first
boutique in Milan’s famous Via della Spiga
shopping district.
At first, his clothing store was just a single
rack of dresses, and yet his talent was still
enough to have women coming in to see his
creations.
Milan is one of the fashion capitals of the
world, so the competition is fierce.
Designers open boutiques all the time, only
for them to not turn a profit, and yet Versace
had the skills to push through.
In order to be successful in any business-
not just fashion- you have to understand your
customer.
Who are they?
And what do they need to make their life better?
For Gianni Versace, he wanted to design clothes
for men and women who were sexy, confident,
and powerful.
And to him, the one person who exemplified
all of the qualities was his younger sister
Donatella.
She has a keen eye for style, and she was
not afraid to share her criticism of her older
brother’s work.
When Gianni designed something that was ugly,
Donatella would tell him immediately.
Eventually, Gianni learned Donatella’s taste
in clothing, and she became his muse.
During several interviews, Gianni shared how
much Donatella inspired him, saying, “She
is my first customer.”
But Donatella wasn’t just the artistic inspiration.
Gianni made her the vice-president of the
corporation when she was still in her early
20’s, and his older brother Santo was the
president.
Even though she was technically vice-president,
Donatella was still very young, and she was
figuring out what she wanted to do with her
life.
Ultimately, she decided that she wanted to
be a fashion designer, as well.
So Gianni started a second brand called Versus,
which existed as a subsidiary of the larger
Versace corporation.
Donatella did all of the designs, and she
began to learn all of the ins an outs of the
fashion business, just like Gianni had when
working in Milan.
To an untrained eye, someone might look at
the Versace family’s designs and assume
that not much thought went into it at all.
Many people have even gone as far as to say
that they are overly sexualized, and the whole
point of the fashion line was to exploit women’s
bodies.
He got a lot of push-back.
Many people said that his dresses were too
vulgar.
A phrase that became famous was: "Armani dresses
the wife, Versace dresses the mistress."
During an interview with Charlie Rose, Versace
responded to these criticisms with a quote
from Friedrich Nietzsche, “Those who know
that they are profound strive for clarity.”
As in- He has the ability to design anything
he wants, and he could do it well.
But he was choosing to design this way for
a very good reason.
Versace hated the fact that somewhere along
the course of human history, it was decided
that men were expected to wear a suit and
tie, and anything else was deemed to be unprofessional.
And for women with beautiful bodies, they
had to hide them away in order to be taken
seriously.
He knew that so many people out there wanted
to express themselves through fashion, and
they were holding back from going outside
of the box out of fear of being judged.
He said, “Don't be into trends.
Don't make fashion own you.
But you decide what you are, what you want
to express by the way you dress, and the way
to live.”
Fame and Fortune
Combined with his visionary fashion sense,
Versace was also a brilliant businessman.
At the time, other major fashion brands weren’t
bothering to head to eastern countries.
They were trying to focus on the west, where
they believed most of the money was.
Versace opened up his first shop in China
in 1979.
Hindsight is always 20/20, of course, but
we know today that establishing himself in
China was an incredibly smart move.
He was always ten steps ahead of the competition.
In the 1980’s and early 90’s, Gianni Versace
continued to open more of his shops all over
the world, and his designs became famous.
He began to dress some of the biggest celebrities
in the world at the time, like Elton John,
Princess Diana, Cher, and Madonna.
Honestly, there were so many celebrity clients
that Versace worked with, we cannot possibly
mention them all in this video.
He also designed costumes for the opera called
Capriccio.
So, even if he could not be a composer, he
was still able to keep his love of music in
his life by dressing both classical singers
and rock stars alike.
Getting celebrity endorsements are critical
for the success of a business, but it can
sometimes just be a flash in the pan, especially
in the world of fashion.
Versace was smart enough to know that in order
for his company to last for future generations,
it needed longevity.
We aren’t going to name names, here, but
there are some luxury fashion companies out
there that have a very snobbish attitude about
who they want their ideal customer to be.
They refuse to make products that are affordable
to the middle-class, because they only want
the richest people to represent them.
Some luxury brands actually burn their products,
because they would rather destroy those pieces
than ever put them on clearance, which would
allow mear peasants to be able to afford to
wear their brand.
For Versace, though, he felt the exact opposite.
He wanted to make his brand more accessible
to a wider audience.
And he knew that by opening it up to anyone,
it would ultimately make the company more
successful.
He began to sell smaller luxury accessories
like jewelry, wallets, perfume, and home decor
items.
While some luxury brands cost thousands of
dollars for a purse or dress, someone can
buy a Versace piece for just a few hundred
dollars.
In turn, his brand’s Medusa logo was seen
by more people.
It’s almost needless to say that at this
point in his life, Gianni Versace had become
a multi-millionaire.
Personal Life
In 1982, Versace’s fashion business was
in full swing.
He fell in love with a fashion model named
Antonio D'Amico.
Gay marriage was not legal at the time, but
they were life partners for 15 years.
D’Amico and Versace would spend time in
Milan, and travel around the world together.
In 1992, they were on a flight to Cuba, and
had a layover in Miami.
Gianni asked their driver to bring him and
Antonio around, just to see what Miami was
like.
Once he saw it, he was shocked at how beautiful
it was, and he knew that he had accidentally
found the location of his new home.
After visiting an area of the city called
South Beach, he saw that there was a community
of young gay men who were not afraid to show
who they truly were.
Growing up in Europe, this level of honesty
and freedom to live out of the closet was
refreshing to Versace, and he was convinced
that this truly was the perfect place for
him and D’Amico to live.
As he was walking along the beach, Versace
spotted a large Mediterranean Revival style
mansion with a statue of the goddess of love-
Aphrodite- sitting in the front courtyard.
He was still a die-hard mythology nerd deep
down, of course.
So once he saw one of this favorite characters,
he took this as a sign that this was going
to be his future home with D’Amico.
He bought this property, and called it La
Casa Casuarina.
The home is truly a slice of Italy sitting
in the middle of Miami.
Even though he was now in his late 40’s
and settled into his forever-home, Gianni
Versace was far from retirement.
He still loved running his business, and he
was eager to continuing improving his designs.
During an interview, he once said, “It’s
like oxygen for me.
I love doing fashion.”
He understood that what is popular in fashion
today might change by tomorrow.
So he would frequent Miami nightclubs.
Instead of dancing in the crowd, he often
sat on the sidelines so that he could pay
attention and study these young, beautiful
people.
According to D’Amico, Versace never drank
alcohol, even in this social setting, because
he wanted to stay sober in order to truly
be present in the moment.
Everyone in the community began to recognize
and respect him.
Some say that he was the “unofficial mayor
of South Beach”
Even though everyone in his personal life
knew about his sexual orientation, Versace
still kept it a secret.
He and Donatella had been considering taking
the company public on the stock market, and
they were afraid that shareholders would not
want to invest if they knew that he was gay.
But in 1995, Gianni Versace made the decision
to finally came out of the closet.
He publicly announced that he was gay, and
had been in a long-term relationship with
Antonio D’Amico.
Gianni Versace was truly modest, and he never
acted as if he was better than anyone else
living in Miami, and even after he had reached
a level of celebrity.
He continued spending time out in the world
among normal people.
While his mindset was admirable, this would
turn out to be a tragic mistake.
The Assassination
In July of 1997, Versace was now 50 years
old.
His designs were on the covers of magazines,
he had been on TV on multiple occasions.
Everyone knew that he was a multi-millionaire,
but he still ran his own errands around town,
just like anyone else.
Versace was well-loved in Miami, always saying
“hello” and being friendly towards the
locals.
According to Antonio D’Amico, Versace was
always willing to help other people, and described
him as being one of the sweetest men who ever
lived.
So he did not make any enemies, and therefore
truly felt safe.
Ironically, Versace often told his friends
that he believed that America was a lot safer
than Italy- mainly because the mafia reigned
in his hometown of Calabria.
On the morning of July 15, 1997, Gianni Versace
left his home to get a cup of coffee and the
newest issues of The New Yorker and Vogue
magazine.
Versace would never expect that he had a stalker
who had been studying his every move.
He was unlocking his front gate, with his
back turned to the street, when a serial killer
named Andrew Cunanan shot him twice in the
back of the head.
With a strange twist of fate, the bullet went
through Versace’s body and hit a nearby
dove, which fell to the ground next to Versace’s
body.
Antonio D’Amico was home, waiting for his
partner to return with his coffee and magazines.
He said, “I heard the shot.
My heart just stopped.
So I ran out, and I saw Gianni lying on the
stairs in blood.”
When the police arrived, they saw the dead
bird lying on the ground next to Versace.
They assumed the dove may be a symbol that
this was a hit by the Italian mob.
But they eventually figured out that the culprit
was Andrew Cunanan, who had already appeared
on America’s Most Wanted for killing four
other men.
During the press conference, it was announced
to the press that Gianni Versace had no connection
to Andrew Cunanan whatsoever.
The FBI had to investigate the connection
between the two.
Eight days later, they finally caught up with
Andrew Cunanan, and he was surrounded by the
police.
He shot himself in the head before the FBI
had a chance to question him.
So no one knows his true motivation behind
killing a famous fashion designer.
Before assassinating Gianni Versace, Andrew
Cunanan was an escort who catered to older,
wealthy men.
Cunanan had a genius IQ, and he had a photographic
memory.
His parents spoiled him rotten, and gave him
absolutely anything he could ever ask for.
Andrew was made to believe that he was better
than everyone else.
Surprise, surprise- he became a narcissist
and a sociopath.
Andrew Cunanan was the polar opposite of Gianni
Versace.
He truly did feel that he was entitled to
have the finest things in life handed to him
without working for it.
Cunanan was incapable of empathy for other
people, and he also became a compulsive liar-
telling everyone he met a different story
about his name, career, parents, and so much
more.
Some speculate that after learning that Gianni
Versace was gay, Andrew Cunanan began stalking
Versace, and that he may have approached him
with the intention of becoming his escort.
In 2018, TV series “American Crime Story:
The Assassination of Gianni Versace” does
a lot of speculating into the possibility
that they may have met before the assassination.
But if you watch it, do so with a grain of
salt.
According to an interview with Antonio D’Amico,
he was insulted by much of what the show claimed,
and he believes that Versace never met Cunanan
before.
After this autopsy, it was revealed that Gianni
Versace had HIV.
Because of this, many speculate that D’Amico
must have been unfaithful, or that they had
an open relationship.
But what we do know for certain is that Donatella
Versace did not like Antonio D’Amico at
all.
In his will, Gianni Versace left D’Amico
an allowance of $57,000 a month, and that
he had the right to live any of the Versace
family mansions around the world.
But Donatella was in charge of the estate,
and she did not want D’Amico to have so
much of her brother’s money and properties.
So they had to go to court.
D’Amico left with a lump sum for his inheritance,
and decided not to fight over living in the
mansion.
After all, it was the place where he witnesses
the love of his life shot and killed.
It was the last place he wanted to live.
Legacy
Donatella Versace took over creative control
of the company after Gianni was killed.
She and her older brother Santo agreed that
they would keep the company private and family-owned.
Without her brother there, she was now the
one and only designer who had to carry on
the Versace legacy.
Years later, she spoke at Oxford University
about how she managed to continue to grow
the brand, even after her brother’s death.
She said, “Fashion is a weapon that you
can use when you need it...My own look makes
people think I'm tough.
It's like armour that was useful to me in
the first years after Gianni's death.
It was difficult to live that pain in public
- and to be compared to him when he was the
genius and I was only ever the accessory.
It was hard to hear people constantly say
'will she make it?'”.
But she did.
Sources vary as to how much the Versace brand
was worth at the time of his death, because
the sales of his clothing truly go down after
he came out of the closet.
Reports of its value vary between $400 and
$700 million.
For the next 11 years, Donatella continued
to grow the company, and in 2018, the Versace
brand was purchased by Michael Kors for $2.1
Billion.
The La Casa Casuarina mansion has been turned
into a hotel and event venue simply called
“The Villa”, and it continues to be a
popular Miami tourist attraction to this day.
Even years after his death, the Versace brand
is still going strong to this very day, and
it will most likely be around for
a long time.